[Music]
on this saturday night
the vaccination marathon in canada
from drive-throughs brings those our
second goals to pop-up clinics
we're definitely not going to get there
unless those who are profoundly vaccine
skeptical are convinced to come around
the push for provinces to meet their
targets troubling signs of the delta
variant and low vaccination rates in the
united states
plus the affordable solution in calgary
empty offices converted
into housing and juneteenth the american
holiday
a reminder of how far it still has to go
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada has hit a major milestone in
the fight against covet 19.
over 75 of eligible canadians have now
received at least
one vaccine dose 20 are fully vaccinated
those are the targets the public health
agency of canada said were needed for
provinces to begin
safely easing restrictions if the path
out of this pandemic
and provinces are pushing hard to see it
through
mike delay has our top story tonight
[Music]
it's not one of those summer festivals
bc residents are used to
and while surry's round the clock
vaxathon will have entertainment
the focus is clearly on the kovit 19
vaccine sure it's a good thing anytime
they can get more needles in people it's
it's good the push to increase
vaccination numbers is well underway
across the country alberta premier jason
kenney is happy enough with 70 percent
of eligible people in the province
getting their first shot
that he announced virtually all health
restrictions would be lifted on july 1st
mass mandates will also be lifted
although municipal rules governing their
use
such as one in calgary may remain in
place
today i want to say we did it you did it
health experts aren't as bullish on
alberta's plan since it was drafted
before the arrival of the delta variant
first discovered in india
it's now the dominant strain in the uk
spreading quickly
amongst unvaccinated people and while
the delta numbers are still
relatively low in canada they're growing
and epidemiologists now say
a 90 percent vaccination rate is likely
needed
for herd immunity so we need all adults
and a fair number of children to get
vaccinated before we reach herd immunity
uh we're definitely not going to get
there unless those
who are profoundly vaccine skeptical are
convinced to come around good morning
everybody how are you doing
[Music]
ontario is taking a more cautious
approach than its western cousins
putting its focus on boosting the
vaccine rate in toronto where 75 percent
of the population
have received at least one shot and 25
percent are fully vaccinated
38 vaccine clinics are now operating
many targeting under-serviced or
hesitant populations
like this one for the indigenous
community they have
variety of reasons historically and
otherwise to be hesitant
about coming to a city run clinic for
example for now the plan in ontario is
to move into stage two of reopening on
july 2nd
to join alberta's mask-less summer more
vaccine hesitant adults
will have to be convinced to roll up
their sleeves microlight global news
toronto
in the united kingdom vaccination
efforts are being ramped up to beat the
delta variant
tens of thousands of people are lining
up across the country
as part of super saturday vaccine
clinics have been set up at several
sports facilities including
london's olympic stadium all adults are
now eligible to get the shot and the
government hopes the mass vaccination
centers will make it easier for everyone
to get the job
so far at least 81 percent of the uk's
adult population
has received at least one dose there's
growing concern the delta variant could
cause a new wave of coven 19 cases in
the united states
the average vaccination rate is now over
50 percent
but in dozens of communities it's less
than 20 percent
and as jackson proskow explains doctors
fear
that could lead to a coven 19 resurgence
reopening is cause for celebration
across the u.s
as covid case counts and deaths dip to
their lowest points in the pandemic
but in the american south there's
concern below
average rates of vaccination coupled
with the highly contagious delta variant
could lead to a brand new wave does the
delta variant change the equation
it does change the equation the virus
spreads more rapidly
you have a much greater chance of
getting it so the vaccine is your one
surefire way of preventing getting sick
lower vaccination rates have been driven
partially by hesitancy
and partially by a belief that the
pandemic is over
in some areas the number of vaccinated
individuals is abysmally low
risking a virus resurgence we have over
a hundred counties in this country right
now that have
less than 20 percent of the residents
vaccinated
those are time bombs waiting to happen
this and virus will find you if you are
not vaccinated
that's already the case in the united
kingdom where a delta variant driven
surge has caused the country to delay
its national reopening
in the u.s delta now makes up about 10
percent of all cases
and is likely to become the dominant
version of the virus soon
it tends to look like it might even be
more serious in making people ill
still doctors expect any new surge to
look different than the ones before it
older and more vulnerable people tend to
be vaccinated at higher rates
meaning fewer potential hospitalizations
this virus has serious complications
serious side effects even in 30 year
olds even in 40 year olds
20 year olds even in the race to
vaccinate
the white house has turned to a more
intimate push working with community
leaders even barber shops to sell the
importance of inoculation
warning the delta variant is so
contagious that it threatens to roll
back the clock on recovery
jackson prosco global news washington
conflicting public health advice has
left canadians confused about what they
should do for their second vaccine dose
especially those who got astrazeneca as
their first
on this week's edition of the west block
mercedes-stevenson talks with one of the
country's
top medical minds about whether
canadians have anything to be concerned
about
as the science and vaccine guidance
evolve
mercedes robin i spoke with dr peter uni
the scientific director of ontario's
covid19
science advisory table he says in order
to get the
optimal solution for everyone the
scientific advice
has to change as scientists get more
information
about how the vaccines work and respond
we're working at high speed as
scientists to get this right
and knowledge evolves what the public
needs to understand is that science
never gives you complete certainty i
mean that's like in life you know
there are no guarantees here we try to
get it as good as it gets
and right now we're really on the right
track i also asked him what many
canadians are wondering about this
summer
if travel restrictions will be relaxed
for the fully vaccinated
what does that mean for families with
small children who are too young to get
a vaccine
dr uni says the priority needs to be on
ensuring that more variants
do not arrive in this country it's clear
if you are not fully vaccinated you will
need to be very careful and from my
perspective this would mean
if we travel with children the children
would need to undergo
the regular quarantine and would need to
get tested repetitively not just once
and that's just how it is right now we
don't have vaccines yet that are
approved for kids
dr uni says he's hopeful by september
vaccines will be approved for children
under the age of 12. robin mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thanks mercedes and
you can watch the full interview
tomorrow on the west block
right here on global the astrazeneca
shot hasn't been approved in the united
states
and it's proving to be difficult to get
into venues in some parts
of the u.s but a broadway production has
just done an about-face on the issue
springsteen on broadway says it will now
allow audience members fully vaccinated
with astrazeneca
it had previously said anyone wishing to
attend needed to be immunized with
u.s approved vaccines but other
attractions like saturday night live and
the tonight show starring jimmy fallon
still say astrazeneca recipients cannot
attend
live tapings many of us have been
waiting for the moment we can begin
traveling again
travel experts say the time to book
flights is now before prices go up
there are good deals out there it all
depends on where and when you want to go
and there are conditions
our business reporter ann gaviola
explains what you need to look for
passenger air traffic has limped along
during the pandemic but as the economy
reopens and quarantine restrictions
ease demand is slowly returning and
there are deals to be found you could
book a flight from toronto to new york
and back for 280 dollars in august or
from calgary to london's gatwick airport
in september for less than seven hundred
dollars a return
there are deep discounts on routes to
major cities that used to have a lot of
business travelers
new york chicago las vegas especially if
you can fly out midweek
but fewer deals for domestic travel and
trips to eastern europe and asia
packages for sun destinations are
selling like hot cakes many hoping to
get ahead of expected price hikes and
book
before they sell out demand is going to
increase
and there's no doubt about it so i think
the
early bird gets the worm here as long as
you can live with the restrictions on
the fair
if you want to make changes airlines are
offering deals hoping to convince people
who've mostly stayed away for the past
year to get on board
with low-cost carriers like flair
airlines which is expanding across the
country
travelers can save a lot if they do some
legwork they really want to encourage
people to start thinking about traveling
again
it's been out of our mind for 18 months
almost now
but experts are advising consumers to
look beyond the lowest possible price
read the fine print to understand what
extra costs could come with a change of
plans
coronavirus variants could shift
re-entry requirements and travel
restrictions
and there's a moving target that's a key
factor that affects prices
the cost of oil fuel is a big cost
factor for the airlines so if the price
of oil is going up
they're either adjusting that in their
in the fares and of course they can set
fares by the hour
anne gaviola global news toronto
despite the threat of the delta variant
many canadian provinces are starting to
reopen
it's been more than a year of
stay-at-home orders and social
distancing
and understandably some canadians may be
reluctant to re-enter society jamie
morocco explains
seeing people gathered on this ottawa
patio tasha stansberry feels triggered
i know that i'm not in danger but it's
more of a sense of what are we doing
the 27 year old is living with social
anxiety
and she says it's making ontario's
reopening a difficult adjustment
definitely the experience of the
pandemic has lowered my sense of
being able to trust the people around me
according to an ipsos poll exclusive to
global news
51 percent of canadians feel anxious
about resuming normal activities
i don't want to be anywhere near a crowd
mother of two paula shuck says her
daughter's already suffered from anxiety
but kovit has added another level of
stress if they've come to the grocery
store
with me to help or something they give
themselves an
hour in the room afterwards because it's
just a lot after being
so isolated although not official this
strange feeling associated to
transitioning into society after endless
lockdowns
has been coined by mental health experts
south of the border
as cave syndrome we've all been at such
a heightened state of vigilance it takes
some time for your body and your mind to
come down
from that psychiatrist sarah levitt says
doing new things a little at a time can
help
it's when anxiety is out of proportion
with the threat
that it can become problematic we see
that from
sars that for some people it was years
afterwards that they
experienced mental health distress in
this case experts suggest
seeking out a professional back in
ottawa although stansberry says she's
vaccinated and wears a mask
even the idea of walking through a
crowded street is nerve-wracking
i'll get a little bit sweaty i'll feel a
little bit short of breath a physical
reaction
she hopes will subside with time jamie
morocco global news toronto
in winnipeg a 12-year-old boy is dead
after being stabbed during a fight
between two groups
it happened last night police arrived to
find the 12-year-old seriously injured
lying on the street he was transported
to hospital where he succumbed to his
injuries
i struggle with finding a word to
describe
this homicide specifically the
involvement of
the 12 year old that became deceased
there's a number of details involved
that are particularly troubling details
that we may be able to share
when our charges are laid there's some
details ultimately that will
perhaps come out when this is dealt with
in the court system
no charges have been laid yet but police
say their investigation has progressed
significantly coming up the coronation
of iran's new president
the subject of u.s sanctions and the
third major storm of the hurricane
season
pummels the gulf coast
tropical storm claudette soaked the u.s
gulf coast
the storm packed winds topping 70
kilometers an hour and dropped up to 250
millimeters of rain
on parts of louisiana mississippi and
alabama
where it also spawned a tornado the
system could affect atlantic canada
early next week
claudette is already the third named
storm of the atlantic hurricane season
which is forecast to be a busy one
iran's hardline chief justice will be
the country's next
president the election of ibrahim raizi
is widely seen as a coronation
because he's the supreme leader's
protege rajisi has been sanctioned by
the united states for his involvement in
the mass execution of thousands of
political prisoners
he may have won by 18 million votes but
there was voter apathy and it led to the
lowest turnout
in the country's history myanmar's
military is condemning a united nations
resolution calling for a global arms
embargo against the southeast asian
country
the rare resolution passed in the
general assembly friday
citing the military's excessive and
lethal violence
since carrying out a coup in february at
least 860 people have died in the
crackdown that followed
myanmar's foreign ministry says the
resolution is based on one-sided
sweeping allegations and false
assumptions
today demonstrators took to the streets
of the country's largest city
to call for the release of
democratically elected leader aung san
tsuchi
she's been detained since the military
seized power nearly five months ago
the protest coincided with her 76th
birthday
working from home and living in offices
still had the plan to fill calgary's
empty core
the pandemic has made working from home
the new normal for many canadians
as a result office buildings across
canada are empty
the latest data shows the office vacancy
rate hit 6.2 percent in vancouver
in toronto is just over 9 percent but in
calgary
it sits at a 32 percent vacancy rate
that city has been struggling to fill
office high rises
and as heather york's west explains
calgary has come up with a solution to
fill those empty spaces
with affordable housing it's called
sierra place a downtown calgary high
rise
that was once the busy office
headquarters for dome petroleum and
other companies
for years now it's been empty part of
the city's growing glut
of vacant office space unbelievably bad
you know i feel like i've said over the
last number of years that the downtown
vacancy problem is unbelievably bad
it's bad now in fact in 2020 calgary's
downtown vacancy rate hit a record high
of nearly 27 percent
and it's not expected to get better
anytime soon there are 16
buildings in the city that are currently
completely vacant
thanks to both the energy sector
downturn and covet 19.
but in this 10-story tower a
transformation is underway
our vision for this project is a
multi-generational family hub
and what this represents to families who
are experiencing homelessness
or on the edge of homelessness is it
represents hope
over the next year these former board
rooms and law offices
will become studio one or two-bedroom
apartments
affordable housing units in a city with
a desperate need for more
it's the first of its kind project in
alberta and a test case many
eyes are on i think there are a lot of
people and a lot of
a lot of levels of government and
partners across the country who are
going to be watching this
calgary city council is hoping the idea
will catch on
in addition to the 5.5 million dollars
in support it's promised
this project the city is also
establishing a 45 million dollar fund
it hopes will entice developers to
remake other vacant office towers as
well
we've had one purely private sector
conversion this is our first attempt at
an affordable housing conversion
it is a bit of an experiment to see how
well it goes but certainly there are
buildings downtown calgary that have
very good bones
a potential solution to two problems
that post pandemic
are certainly not calgary's alone
heather eric's west global news
calgary to elephant watch in china
the now famous herd that's trekked
hundreds of kilometers
could be heading home the team that's
been tracking the 15 elephants says the
herd has shown a trend of returning
south
but scientists still can't figure out
the herd's specific route
the elephants left their wildlife
reserve in march of 2020 that was 15
months ago
their epic road trip has received
international attention
up next the official end of slavery is
officially a u.s holiday
[Applause]
the group black lives matter held a
rally outside prime minister justin
trudeau's office demanding changes to
the justice system
and renewing a call to defund the police
the demonstration
included families of black and
indigenous people who died
during interactions with police that
event took place as americans mark
juneteenth the anniversary of the end of
slavery in the united states
on june 19 1865 enslaved black people in
galveston texas learned
the civil war was over and the
emancipation proclamation
had freed them two and a half years
earlier more than 150 years later
juneteenth is now finally a federal
holiday
here's jennifer johnson
[Music]
from boston to san francisco juneteenth
is finally being celebrated across the
u.s
some people don't realize that
juneteenth is america's story they think
it's solely a black story this is a
story of all america
on this day in 1865 union army general
gordon granger came to galveston texas
and informed the last american slaves
they were free
two months after the civil war had ended
and over two years after the signing of
the emancipation proclamation
think about that for more than two years
the enslaved people of texas were kept
in servitude
after swift passage in both the house
and senate u.s president joe biden
signed a law
making juneteenth an official national
holiday this is a day
profound in my view profound weight and
profound power
many americans even those in galveston
never knew of june 19's history
why artist reginald adams painted this
mural in the city
i want people to be inspired and
hopefully learn something that they
didn't know before they saw the work of
art
black americans have waited decades for
this holiday to be recognized on a
federal level
nine states had already designated
juneteenth as an official paid state
holiday
june many others had resolutions and
proclamations
only south dakota does not mark the day
in any form
but after the death of george floyd and
demonstrations that followed
there was a renewed spotlight on racial
injustice in america
and a greater push to remember this
important day in history
we were all in the same valley of
suffering together
the sand was shifting underneath all of
us at the same time
the biden administration is being
praised for its action with some fellow
lawmakers taking additional steps
requiring the history of this day to be
taught in schools
with this change the people of illinois
will have a day to reflect
on how the freedom that we celebrate
just
two weeks later on the fourth of july
was delayed
to black americans now all americans
will at least recognize the name of this
holiday
while many others will have an official
day to celebrate it
jennifer johnson global news washington
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is this field of horses near
gore bay on manitoulin island in ontario
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you